latest trend in travel vaccines new york
has set up mobile pop-up vaccination
sites aimed at out-of-towners
alaska now offers shots to tourists as
soon as they step off the plane
right in the airport from the maldives
to the micro state of
san marino to moscow vaccine tourism is
taking off around the world
but it's not without detractors lucy
craft has this report from the american
island
of guam the u.s territory of guam is a
sleepy compact
island about 3 000 miles west of hawaii
its main attraction beaches palm trees
and sunsets
for more than a year guam's instagram
perfect
aquamarine waters have been nearly
deserted
imperiling livelihoods for a third of
its workforce
but in recent months officials noticed a
steady stream of americans
living in asian countries with slow
vaccine rollouts
flying in to get their shots americans
like us no sun and sand on this trip
i've just finished a week in quarantine
to be able to come here to the
university of guam field house
for my coronavirus shot lou leon
guerrero is a registered nurse
she also happens to be the governor of
guam
i kept up my license i figured you know
if they fire me
i still have a job with most of her
constituents inoculated
governor leon guerrero said guam is
launching vaccine tourism packages for
u.s expatriates
the win-win is really all over the place
we can vaccinate
the u.s expat and in the meantime
they're having a nice time in guam
they're enjoying the hospitality we are
benefiting from their
economic input as a result of that
pre-pandemic
guam drew nearly 2 million visitors
mostly from japan
south korea and it aims to extend
vaccine vacations to
asian travelers immunizing americans is
one thing but wooing
foreign tourists with vaccines health
experts like binghamton university's
nicole hassoun say
is an ethical gray zone there's people
who really really need that vaccine
who aren't getting it and that's where
the vaccine should go and shouldn't be
prioritizing people just because they're
wealthy enough to come to the united
states
but spurred by similar schemes across
the u.s
guam is banking on vaccine tourism to
help refill its beaches this summer
and provide a shot in the arm to its
flatlining tourist industry
for cbs this morning saturday lucy kraft
hagatna guam count this among the
expressions i've never
thought i'd hear 15 months ago vaccine
tourism right yeah right well i can't
see governor andrew cuomo or
phil murphy giving the show giving the
shot
probably because they're not medical
professionals yeah but you know i
love seeing the governor doing too yeah
and the good news is that some of the
richer uh wealthier nations
have now said they're going to get shots
to as mentioned in peace the places
it
that